if you was on a stakeout you know felix
brought the champagne and caviar are you
going that
oozy like what are you bringing
[Laughter]
why not i mean it is hard to imagine
having a lot of like feelings and
emotions and being sad
and eating caviar and drinking champagne
but why not right if he's bringing
if somebody's bringing it i'm i'm yeah
i'm doing it
yeah i'm i'm probably drinking a greasy
a greasy bag or something
maybe some buffalo wings just gonna make
it messy
[Laughter]
sophia it's been like 17 years
can you hear me yeah yeah so
you know 17 years since lost in
translation with bill murray
how do you find that you two have um
your relationship has evolved and how
has how has working with them changed
since that time you directed them back
in 2003.
well we've we've grown up together now i
didn't know it was so long
um yeah it was just it was just really
fun to
be reunited and um you know we've become
friends over the years
so i just knew i could count on him and
i and also rasheeda
is friends with him too so i uh and i we
all work together briefly so
um so it was great to work with him now
at this
at this point in my life where i have a
little more experience than the first
time around
it's been 17 years wait that's really
not
on me really i didn't realize that
that's crazy
[Music]
it took me that long to grow a beard so
and it's not even that long i know
i'm sorry wait to the next 18 years to
be crazy
it feels like 17 years since last summer
no wow one of the big themes here
is um trying to get back to work and
and be creative after starting your
family
and all the responsibilities and
emotions that go along with that
um sophia rashida can you can you speak
to how that
um the messages you wanted to get across
in this movie with regards to that
yeah i mean i think i think you know for
women it is especially hard
you know we we are kind of sold this
myth that we can have it all but the
truth is you can't have it all at the
same time
you do have to prioritize it's
impossible not to and
and i think you know being a mom
is it's it's all-encompassing it's not
even you know it's not like a job that
you can a part-time job that you can
take on it's like
has to be your main focus it has to be
even if you want to be a working mom
i think everybody i know who's a working
mom they feel
torn when they're at work they feel torn
to the home when they're home they feel
torn to the work i mean now we're all
it's all kind of in the same place but
it's really really difficult to
understand the word balance
as a working mom and i think you know i
think a lot of
a lot of women relate to that you guys
had the uh
the big new york film festival thing
around the same time as as bill murray's
birthday it must have been great all
getting back together again
did it i mean you had i saw the one
photo where you guys were able to take
your masks off how does it feel to
actually be able to be in person to
celebrate this together
uh it was fun the night at the drive and
i didn't know what
to expect but i was so happy that um
that marlin
and bill and rashida could all be there
um and yeah who would have thought we'd
be in a
you know in a field in queens but it was
it was fun it was the first time we
watched the movie together
and um and it was a really memorable
night
and i was in a separate country watching
all them watch the movie together
and me and my driver we we we just had a
we had a ball
he got teary-eyed for a minute i hugged
him
it was a great time everyone's scared of
the world traveler
that's great well thank you so much i
gotta wrap now but thanks so much for
your time
thank you uh thank you very much
you